Netflix gives you like a certain amount
of money basically then you have to
decide how much to spend on producing
the special then how much to keep is
that kind of right yeah yeah it's kind
of a shield but they they're smart
businessmen because they know we want to
be on Netflix so they give you a couple
a couple bucks you gotta shoot it edit
it promote it all the stuff they used to
do yeah because I was thinking based on
what you see in podcasts and things it
seems like the ongoing joke about you
amongst your peers is that you're very
money conscious I think Shane Gillis was
the one talking about you eating like
the random Leftovers on the Tuesdays
with stories live so is it hard for you
to make these huge financial decisions
for something like that's so expensive
like producing a Netflix quality special
that's a great question there fatty but
the real problem is I'm cool with buying
big I bought a brownstone in Brooklyn I
bought a BMW a vintage car which was a
huge uh money suck but I'm not good at
buying stuff for me like a smoothie or a
new underwear